we're going to begin with a major
development in the Fallout from the
January 6 attack four members of the
far-right extremist group The Proud boys
convicted of seditious conspiracy
including the group's former leader
Enrique tario and three others all found
guilty of sedition's conspiracy for
plotting the attack a fifth man was
found not guilty of that charge and
Scott McFarland has made his way to the
federal courthouse in Washington Scott
big news good morning
Tony good morning to you it was a
landmark case at a potentially pivotal
victory for the justice department which
could Empower Federal prosecutors to
bring more cases against more people
accused of plotting to overturn the 2020
election
during a marathon four-month trial
prosecutors cast members of The
far-right Proud Boys As Leaders of the
mob who consider themselves Donald
Trump's Army January 6 will be a day in
infamy the jury convicted four of the
five on several charges including
seditious conspiracy plotting to block
the peaceful transfer of power in
America the justice department will do
everything in its power to defend the
American people and American democracy
the jury found a fifth defendant Dominic
pizzola of New York who used a police
riot shield
to smash a window and Lead rioters
inside not guilty of seditious
conspiracy but guilty on other charges
prosecutors successfully argued proud
boy's leader Enrique tario conspired
seditiously January 6th even though he
wasn't in Washington that day but was
instead coordinating and celebrating the
attack at a Baltimore Hotel messaging
make no mistake we did this does this
open the door
to the feds charging more people who
weren't actually there January 6th it
empowers the doj to go after others uh
it further empowers the special counsel
uh in the additional investigation
surrounding the 2020 presidential
elections during trial prosecutors
linked the proud boys January 6 violence
to Donald Trump's words playing a clip
of trump from a 2020 presidential debate
I promise stand back and stand by that
moment changed my life forever former
proud boy Jeremy bertino became a star
witness for the prosecutors testifying
the group wanted an all-out Revolution
and to stop the transfer of power I
think these guys got what they deserved
you lead an attempted coup and you go to
jail
seditious conspiracy carries a maximum
sentence of 20 years in prison more than
1 000 people have been charged so far in
the U.S Capitol attack and so far the
Department of Justice has secured a
partial or full conviction in every
single trial to go to a jury Nate
that's not surprising at all the feds
typically have a conviction rate of 90
percentile all right Scott thank you